Okay.
So today is about the notion of anime and,
and Anna Amuse seems to be
a very simple notion. Um,
um,
animal meat means the state of normalness
ness and therefore it's very easy to
interpret. It looks like it is very
easy, easy to interpret them and Ami, uh,
ivy or show that's far from
the case. Uh, uh, in fact,
Durkheim has a pretty
complex notion about, um,
uh, abnormalities, uh, um, uh,
in the transition to and market economy,
uh,
in the transition to modernity.
But before I do, so let me come back
to the issue of the division of Labor,
uh, in, uh, in Durkheim, um, uh,
um, uh, though, um, you know,
he stages the book,
we had the idea of collective conscience,
um, and, uh,
goes along blanks explaining why he's
using a law as an indicator of collective
conscience and be discussed at great
lengths when it comes to describing the
different of the crucial differences
between mechanical and organic solidarity.
He doesn't make much out of it are,
uh,
what drives the analysis of the,
this, this distinction, right?
Bri, modern and modern
societies. Uh, to put
the closure criteria is
actually the division of Labor,
but drives the story is
the division of Labor. Uh,
so in this sense,
in fact,
I think Durkheim can be understood as
being greatly inspired by Adam Smith.
Right?
Who also,
so evolution of human
societies as you recall,
as a gradual evolution
of the division of Labor.
I do again just does not offer such
a complex or sophisticated Betty or
digitization of society's flight hunting,
gathering and animal husbandry
and agricultural and commercial.
He just makes these bipolar distinction
between mechanical and organic.
But if you ask,
well yes,
there is a difference in the legal system,
but what is fundamentally
different is the division of labor.
Mechanical Solidarity has little division
of Labor based on similarity of the
actors in the society.
Uh,
organic solidarity has a great
deal of division of Labor and,
and uh, uh, uh, agreed
deal of the Similac,
the similarity of the action.
And this is puzzling
because the question is,
if it is such a high level of division
of labor and such a great diversity there
on earth, solid additive will come
from how we hang together. So that's,
I think we should appreciate how important
the division of Labor for Smith from
Durkheim was. Uh, by
the way, in some ways,
even the early Mark's, uh, in, uh,
uh,
the,
the German ideology also tried his
stereo digitization of society with the
division of Labor. So I think this is
also the influence of Adam Smith's.
So I seen that as a clear
Adam Smith impact, uh, on, on,
on the vertical of Durkheim,
uh, on, on, on the types of, uh,
uh, a solidarity. There is also
another issue I would like to, uh,
mention. Um, uh, uh,
I pointed out that how important,
right Montesquieu avast
for Durkheim and uh, um,
it's, it's obvious. He ethnologists
is that two Montesquieu,
uh, start, uh, the book,
uh, Vietnam, uh, uh, um,
uh, uh, uh,
collective conscience and the
notion of, uh, um, uh, and,
and law as the best empirically a
observable indicators of this collective
conscience comes of course, directly
do Montesquieu, but that is an odder,
uh,
less frequently notice
the impact of Montez Cure,
uh,
on Durkheim.
And that makes actually a very
interesting orderer for us today.
Uh,
as I mentioned,
I met really has an impact today with
his later Varick as the cultural or an
analyst.
But in his early Virg,
he responded to an
other, uh, Eh and eh, uh,
stimulating idea of Montesquieu.
And that is the, uh,
uh,
interaction between social system and the
environment and the ecological system.
Uh, I mean, uh, I vent at some lengths
in the lecture on Montesquieu, uh,
to show how important it was and how
unique Montesquieu his contribution was.
Ellen, how important it is for us today,
though he made it in a very naive,
a Durkheim actually has a much more
sophisticated and complex understanding,
uh, off the relationship
between an environment.
Um, and, uh, uh, uh, society, uh,
and the type of source of solidarity
and the Division of Labor in society,
uh, or on, unfortunately,
this is a sort of a neglected
element in Durkheim too bad because,
uh, in fact, uh, you know,
the problem of environment and studying
and environment should be a central
issue in economics,
political science,
sociology and anthropology.
And it is not quite as
central as it should be. Uh,
especially I think in political
science and sociology and anthropology,
the study of the environment is too
narrowly focused on environmental social
movements. There are, there kind of
has a different interesting thing,
uh,
which I think a should inspire a
social researchers be the economists,
political scientists, sociologists
and Anthropologists. What is it?
Their time in the division of
Labor has a core of an idea,
but one can call the ecosystem,
right?
Uh,
he sees a interrelationship
between the physical environment,
the size of population,
which lifts in this physical environment,
the technology which is used, uh, uh, uh,
in these environment and the division
of labor and the type of social
organization,
what we have,
what kind of social solidarity you have.
Let me just put this on the blackboard.
Uh,
I think this is a rarely naughtiest.
You will rarely here in
Durkheim's lectures or rarely
read about this when you
read, uh, uh, uh, about Durkheim. Uh,
so the idea here is that you
have, uh, uh, the environment.
You have the population,
you have technology,
and you have social organization,
and it's constitute a system
which interacts with each other.
It's,
and what ought to be studied is reality.
This whole system. And you know,
of course technology has a lot
to do with the division of Labor,
right?
And that's what can be called the
ecosystem. I, he doesn't call it this way,
but environmental researchers would
call it today as the ecosystem.
Um, and I think this is an
extremely productive way, uh,
for social scientists to think about
the problems of environment. Right? Uh,
and let me give you an example. Uh, uh,
why don't you think about
southern California, right?
Southern California,
uh,
before the Europeans
appeared on the scene,
it was a very, uh, uh,
dry climate suffered from
the lack of water resources.
So the Los Angeles basin probably could
accommodate a livelihood for something
like 20,000 people,
right?
These 20,000 people,
Lived in this very arid environment,
loose used very elementary technologies,
and very had a very limited
division of labor. Uh,
so the population size was greatly
affected with the technology and the
environment,
and they had mechanical solidarity.
That was the way how
society was organized. Now,
today, uh, we figured
out how to solve the, the
hydraulic problems for the Los
Angeles basin for the time being.
Uh,
don't hold you abreast because in
no time we may have a major crisis.
So in the same bed as it based
in 20,000 people live now,
20 million people live,
but the live with a very
high level of technology, uh,
we successfully pollute
the air, which is, uh, uh,
write a hard,
hard to breeze in downtown Los Angeles
during a hot summer day. Right.
Um, uh, and we have of course, um, uh,
organic solid Daddy Thi
operating right large and the,
you know, manage to screw the environment.
Thank you quite nicely. You know,
and we keep doing it in no time.
The La base in VOB on inhabitable.
Right.
That's why I think it is
interesting to think about, uh,
these do Camian idea of ecosystem,
how it interacts. As I said,
it would offer you a very rigorous
scientific field framework,
uh, to study the interaction
right. Between Social Organization,
the demographic pro problem, the
technological issues, right. And,
and uh, um, uh, and it's a
relationship how we can leave,
if he can be useful, if it
the environment. Anyway,
it's just a backdrop because,
uh, uh, uh,
to show again the sensuality of
the division of Labor for time.
Now today I will talk about,
uh, um, annual me. Um,
and anime is one of the abnormal,
uh,
concept Vance's, uh, for,
uh, the division of Labor.
Uh,
and well,
this is a one off the troubling
aspects of Derek Hansen. Eric,
uh,
the whole idea of abnormality or
social better ologies and he has been
criticized about this. I agreed the, um,
how do we know of what is abnormal and Ho,
Ho,
Ho how on earth can we tell what
is the normal state of sociality?
Pathology does assume,
right?
There's social researchers has some
way how to judge what is the house see
condition for society.
And this comes from Durkheim's,
uh,
early functionalism as I said,
right?
He was greatly influenced by biology.
It was not a biologist my any means.
But as I pointed out,
the whole metaphor of organic
solidarity uses the human body,
right? And as the example, right? Uh,
how in the human body,
divers or guns depend on each other to
reproduce each other and therefore better
divert pathology is also
borrowed from medical sciences.
So [inaudible] we all have
better logic or features as well,
and there are abnormalities in society
and somehow believes that social
researchers will be able to establish
what abnormality is and what better bet.
Bet apologies are. This is, I think,
troubling for most social
scientist, right? We first,
we seem to have some commitment to at
least value neutral type of analysis,
right?
We,
in which we do not labor
necesarrily phenomena out,
right? You know, labeling theory,
you may have heard about it,
uh, you label something as
criminal or abnormal, uh,
simply because it's probably
unusual in society. Um, what bots,
what was abnormal in one society may
become absolutely normal in another
society. So we have to be
extremely careful, right? We,
the notion of normal and abnormal,
uh,
let's say,
being gay until fairly
recently a vos scene,
I mean,
except a antiquity,
but for most human societies and most
of the cultures being gay is seen as a
kind of abnormal behavior.
Today,
very few people will think about this,
at least in a country
like the United States,
that somebody gay is an
abnormal, right? Uh, uh,
so what sexual behavior is normal or more,
more depends on the times,
right?
It's really not the job of the social
scientists to be able to decide,
you know, what kind of sexual behaviors
should be called normal or abnormal.
The best we can do.
Why owners,
some people call some sexual practices,
abnormal law and order's normal.
Why is there differences in our society
accepting some kind of sexual behaviors
and not the others?
Right. That is a question.
Was social scientists good study
anyway, this is a, I think literally,
um, um, uh, a problem, uh, in, in, uh, uh,
for contemporary social
scientists, uh, uh, uh,
Durkheim's Rurik.
But anyway,
he did believe that he is capable to show,
uh,
that some abnormal development do
take place. He was a specialty,
as I pointed all that the last
lecture out on the transition from,
uh, um, uh, mechanical to
organic solidarity and the,
then that happened then,
uh,
pet pathologies good and merge.
And again,
put it into the social context.
Durkheim is writing in the 1890s and
early 19 hundreds is in Bordeaux and then
he's moving to Paris. The
city of the sin, right.
And he sees all the science
of social pathologies, right?
Uh,
our core holism and homelessness and
prostitution and theft than crime,
uh, which was in existent or
much rarer in rural France,
uh,
adjust a couple of decades ago.
So he's confronted right with massive
phenomena which is being seen as abnormal
or petrologic car and he identifies them
as the results of the transition from
mechanical to organic solidarity.
Well,
pathologies can have two different routes.
Um,
and uh,
what we normally understand
from a Durkheim that he
identifies pathologies from
the absence of rules.
That's what the term enemy refers to.
But interestingly enough,
I have the citations for you and
if you have read the text scale,
you've found the citations as well.
He actually also does consider
that pathologies can also
reserve the result from
the overregulation right of
two forced division of labor.
I think it's very intriguing to see this
because we normally control Paul's Marx
theory of alienation and Durkheim's
theory of anime as Durkheim is complaining
that is not enough regulation in society
by Marxists arguing that it's too much
than [inaudible] in society.
And Ivy,
I'll give you a number of
citations now, uh, from, uh, uh,
Durkheim each actually,
we are sure that the difference between
Rice and labor is not such gigantic as
we initially made. I have salt on
generally of would assume that, uh,
uh, there of is quite sensitive
to some of the Marxian analysis,
even to the marks Jia notion of
alienation. He doesn't use the term,
but it gets very close to it.
So let me just move on.
Third and, um, uh, dark
about better largest bet.
Bet ologies may charge
coming from the absence of,
of rules. Now, uh, and
I've used briefly say,
uh, these interesting, uh, uh,
idea that in fact division of labor
can be the source of solidarity.
As I said, this is counterintuitive. Uh,
we did believe that solid the solidarity
crumbs from relatively small size
communities where people
are relatively similar,
share the same values and the same system,
same norms,
and then they will have a
solid artistic feelings store,
watch each other and people are very
different and they are competing on the
market place. There are the, uh, you know,
our strangers in this sort of cities,
they don't know each other. Uh, uh, the,
the separate subscribe to
different values, uh, uh,
or they even don't know what values
they should obey because the are fused,
they just left the village and ended at
the big end sinful city and they don't
really quite know can I do here anything?
Is that any control over
me or not? I, you know,
it's all up to me what to do.
Even stealing is all right,
sunny my buddies or, right. Ah,
I see other people who do that.
Why don't I do it? The are not
being quote, I probably will not to,
could be caught either.
So that is a kind of right under
these circumstances when that are no,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, similarities.
Why owners, uh, will be solid that estate.
We don't know how other people, and they
have these stereotypes that, you know,
in urban industrial society, we
are not solely that estate. Right.
Uh, uh, this is the, yeah,
the usual stereotypes.
You say you go to New York City,
right?
And that is somebody who is dying on
the streets and other people are just
stepping over that
person, right? Who Cares?
You can die on the street and that will
be hundreds of passengers going by and
left to die. It's actually
not true. Right? Um,
if you ever have seen anybody, uh,
you know, feeling, feeling ill,
uh, uh, in Times Square,
I mean that are usually a lot of people
rush to it and say, are you all right?
Or that's kind of stuff. Um, but
anyway, but you know, the stereotype,
right? Um, uh, so usual
stereotypes about cities anyway,
so it's puzzling why a society which is
so different and nonmembers and such a
high division of labor
can be solid that asleep.
Then he defines various pathologies.
And interesting,
the battle laundry one
sounds very similar,
very close to Mark's Mel.
That is crisis in the system and that
is increasing class conflict and this
cross country to psychological.
Um, and the second one,
uh,
well against something which is
not all that different from walled.
Karl Marx,
uh,
division of labor can be too excessive
and too much division of labor.
Uh, can lead to better logical
consequences. And finally,
his unique contribution that pathology
can come from the lack of regulation.
And that's what he calls an
me. Oh, let me, um, uh, uh,
work on this and also the concept
of an anime a little more.
So here it is a the division of
labor as a source of solidarity,
right? He said, well,
normally the division of labor
produces social solidarity.
Uh, well, but it can happen, uh,
that that are the opposite results.
All right?
So therefore he said,
when we know when division
of Labor Creates Social Sa,
so solidarity,
then it will be better
equipped to figure it out.
Then actually,
social solidarity has
better logical consequences.
And as you can see from the
citation, he directly site, uh,
the medical, um, uh, uh,
metaphor right here as elsewhere.
But ology is a pressures
and Ciliary to physiology.
So you start with the
physiology of society, uh,
you identify when it works normally and
then you will be able to show than it is
better logic though, right?
That's the fundamental idea.
And this seemed that way.
How he tries to get off the hook of
the problem that he actually capable to
tell. What is special logic pro.
All right now the first battle out,
but pathology,
it's actually about class conflict.
He said, well, uh, and
I think mark would have,
would not have been particularly
unhappy with this citation, right?
As labor becomes increasingly divided,
there are commercial crises that are
bankruptcy's that is hostility between
Labor and capital. And then, you know,
all these conflicts
become more frequent right
now in traditional societies
in mechanical solidarities,
well this class conflict
were rare and unusual.
Now, uh, today, uh,
they are not all that on the usual
and he uses the term Verking class.
Right?
You said part of the Virgin class two
or three really desire the state to
society, right? Well, not
quite a theory of exploitation,
but certainly,
uh,
an expression that do high
level of division of labor
in absence of other can't
create in dance class conflict,
which is a pathological consequence
of high division of labor.
Then he goes on and he writes
about excessive division of labor.
Uh,
well he has not tread
the patties manuscripts,
which was not published
of course, um, for uh,
14 more years after he died.
But yeah,
you will have read the pedis manuscripts
and you can see this interesting pedals.
The individual will isolate
himself in his own activity.
He will no longer be over there of the
collaborator who Varick at his side on
the scene task he has even not longer.
And the idea at all what the common
tasks consists is not that's miraculous.
He could not have the faintest idea that
a work called the patties manuscripts
exists. Right. And hear what is
being described is getting very,
very close to the idea of alienation.
Right.
And in fact comes very close to
the Marxian notion of Eliana,
you're not the Hague Eliana run the
Marxian notion because he roots it into
excessive division of labor.
Too much market, right? Uh,
too much competition creates
this situation. Well,
I think this is me innocuous.
And very often, you know,
these sentences are kind of skipped
over as a kind of through over a line.
Uh,
by the time it isn't,
it is very important to identify
what his unique contribution is.
And this is indeed the emphasis that a
pathology can occur out of the lack of
regulation and lack of regulation means,
and on me now,
uh,
he said,
well,
if he's not necessarily for social
life to be visceral struggle,
struggle in itself is not that bad at all.
The role of organic story reality
is not to abolish a competition,
but to moderate it. All right. Well,
I just want to remind you,
um,
this Niv, uh, reminds us to Adam Smith.
He's sympathetic theory of
human nature, right? Uh, well,
uh,
on limited competition is not right,
right.
Unlimited egoistic behavior is not right.
They have to be sympathetic
to the other person, right?
The are struggling for
recognition by others, right.
That is the idea where that is a
similarity in Durkheim's and Adam Smith's
analysis. But, but then he
couldn't, but he, then he continues.
But in some cases, and this is
crucial, there's regulatory process,
which rates competition I there does
not exist at all or not related to the
degree of development of the division
of Labor. It is insufficient.
The that are,
I don't know,
regulations or not enough regulations.
If then division of labor
does not produce solidarity.
It is because the relationship
between organs are not regulated.
And this is what I call an army,
right?
And again,
you see the social context a,
this is exactly coming from uh,
the empirical reference point.
Rural young people get on
the train and that, uh,
get off the train in God's Love Jar San
Lozar and then they walk into the street
in Wyatt, Paris, the sinful city of Paris,
and they are lost.
Suddenly their value system,
what they were told back home in the
village collapses right back in the
village. They knew exactly
what they are supposed to do.
Everybody knew them and they also knew
if they are breaking the laws right of
the community to have your be immediately
punished because there'll be a big
gossip spreading it around
and get back to home.
And Mom and dad will exactly here,
but you have done on the street what
you've were not strict post to do.
Now you are in Paris, more buddy
has the finger study or who, what,
who you are. And even when you don't
know about other people expect from you,
right? It looks like this
is the realm of freedom.
You can do anything, right?
Well, back home in the village,
uh, if you've really engaged,
you would bash her, go,
not hold hands with another
partner on the street, right?
Because then the gossip,
you're back to your fiancee and her
parents or his parents and your parents
immediately. And Darryl,
there'll be a scandal.
Now if you are walking,
Gone Bull Mish,
uh, you can do anything. You
can't hold the handle of anybody.
You can kiss anybody, right?
Nobody knows who you are. Right?
So that's it. You know, at
that is the problem, right,
of anime that people enter
in a [inaudible] society
in which they are lost.
Um, uh, well, uh,
let me just labored a little longer on
the idea and here again see that even the
notion of anime, uh, I mean it's probably,
I don't know whether
how much it is making,
he's making his argument too
complex or Mark's idea of,
uh, uh, uh, uh,
area nation was too complex.
But you can see here against some
similarities even between anime and the
Marxian notion of alienation.
He said the division of Labor may reduce
the worker to the role of a machine.
He's not over here of where the
operation required of him are leading.
And he does not link them
to any AME woo every day.
He repeats the same movements,
monotonous regularity,
but without having any understand
the interest in understanding that,
oh, how interesting. And that's where, uh,
in, uh, uh,
during games thinking the
lack of norms or values,
the collapse of the value
system leading to, uh,
and for him, of course,
that's a big difference.
The solution is to fix
the system of value,
to fix the system of norms and then
you solve the problem of alienation.
But he also said that look and Ami is
not an inevitable consequence of the
division of labor, right? Um, uh, very,
he has a conception that,
you know,
live division of labor can be
forced and can be excessive,
right?
There must be in
elements in the collective
conscience, which moderate, right?
The competitive elements
of the division of Labor.
But if those institutions, you
know, cultural, legal, moral,
ethical institutions are in place,
then in fact,
uh, the division of Labor
will not produce anime.
It only will produce
such if there is no such,
um, uh, systems. But then he said,
don't do not read to me as a romantic.
I don't want to idealize the village
community that these boys and girls and
God, Lazard are coming
out of the train. Right?
I don't want to send the
back to the rural village.
I'm not advocating Yeti turn from
organic solidarity to mechanical, sorry.
That if the all the time showing under
what circumstances that are pathological
contact fancies, right? Uh,
in organic solidarity and therefore
we have to find the proper medication,
the proper cocktail of drugs by
which we can cure these disease.
Right. That is the key idea. Well,
and now another very
interesting, uh, argument,
uh,
which is usually neglected
and reading at the time.
He said,
look,
that are pathologies in society which
are coming from overregulation and forced
division of Labor. Uh, well this is,
uh, already in, uh, the uh, uh,
division of labor,
but a crucial text is in fact the
so-called second introduction into the
division of Labor.
Uh,
doodle can receive a lot of criticism
of the first edition of the division of
Labor was criticized of
being too conservative
politically and that's when he
wrote her, um, the second, uh, uh,
introduction to the division of Labor.
And if you are interested
at all in Durkheim,
you have to read the second introduction,
the introduction to the second edition
of the division of Labor because here he
tries to offer,
uh,
some quote unquote progressive
solution to the problems of uh,
uh, uh, uh,
an Omi and the nature of
a solidarity in organic,
uh, societies, uh, um, uh, um,
uh,
how to overcome the problem of
class conflicts in modern society.
And that his idea is that reality is
solid, that it is, this is the idea.
He develops in the, uh, uh, uh,
introduction to the second edition that
we are becoming a solidaristic vision.
Our professions decided to professional
organizations in which reveal,
find our identities and solidarities.
So he sees the good society as a woven
into multiplicity of professional
organizations in which people fit into
this professional environment and do have
a strong professional identity and
solidaristic attitudes towards the
profession. Uh, uh, this is right.
A radically different
idea right from the mark.
It's not dealing with markets,
not messing up with the markets or not,
not messing up too much with the
Americas to put it this way. And I, uh,
you know, professional
organizations, if they are effective,
they do mess up with the markets,
right?
American Medical Association does mess
up because it's the kind of trade union,
right? Which, um, uh, make
sure that, uh, um, uh,
uh, the doctor's interests that are
being, uh, particualry raptor incentive.
Um, anyway, uh, this is, uh,
uh, the second introduction.
But what is interesting in, in, in
this citation is that he said, well,
uh, the autology can emerge
actually from excessive level of,
uh, of, uh, uh, uh, regulation or force,
division of, of, of labor.
And he introduces an another notion here,
and this is fatal asthma.
So there are these two different
pathologies, uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh, modern societies, uh,
or one is emerging in the transition
from Bethanny got to organic solidarity
given the absence of a
commonly shared values.
Uh,
and that's an Omi.
And that is another basketball
on the other end of the scale.
You have to excessive regulation.
And then people become fatalistic because
then they think there is nothing they
can do, right. And Ami is when you
can't eat anything goes, you know,
I can get her wavy tenor thing, right?
Or are you are desperate, you know,
because you don't know a
Vato nurse, uh, um, uh,
uh, you, uh, uh, Avanto duvet yourself.
A fatalism is a, when you think fell, um,
I have no control over my life.
I am overregulated right?
And then you'll become fatalistic.
It doesn't matter.
Nothing matters because,
uh, uh, it's overregulated.
Okay. Uh, now let me just very briefly,
I compare, uh, uh, these, uh, uh, uh,
three ideas, uh, uh, for, uh, uh,
uh,
Mark's a Viber and Durkheim.
Uh,
I hope I did not confuse you too much
with some of the citations which are quite
contrary,
intuitive,
but it's important to see the
sophistication of the analysis.
Uh, the bottom line of
all this, he said, look,
my unique contribution to the study of
pathologies of modern society is the
theory of anime have each says that
temporarily in this transition,
uh, we have, uh, a problem
of absence of rules.
This will be overcome because there
is no reason by a properly moderated
competition and division of Labor could
not create actually very high levels of
solidarity.
And the mechanism he suggest
in the second introduction is,
you know,
creation of a professional organization
and slotting people into professional
communities. As such, they are
not going back to the villages,
but they will be sort of belonging to
professional communities and having
solidaristic ideas and identities there.
So this is the kind of a bottom line.
He is sensitive to the
problems of is talking about,
he understands that yes,
modern society does create class conflicts
and this is a problem because they're
working class very often
feels ill cheated, uh,
doesn't use the term exploit
it, but you know, it's um, uh,
unhappy with the position assigned to it.
So she sees this is a problem.
He also sees the problem that
an excessive, um, uh, um,
uh, division of labor may create a
sense of, it doesn't use the term,
but really what he means
alienation, right? Um, and he also,
his flight over here that too much
regulation also can create a pathological
state of mind fatalism. Uh, so, uh,
but the major contribution is,
as I've said,
and on me as a insufficient
regulation in society,
this is his unique contribution.
Now, alienation as we have seen,
um, is more like theory collision,
right? In Durkheim it comes, uh,
from, uh, too much that you wish.
And then we have a Weber's notion
of this enchantment, right?
The loss of the enchanted garden. This
is all, all coming, you know, the kind of
mood or feel the human
condition under modernity,
right? These are three different
dates for vulnerabilities.
The loss of magic. All right. Um, and, uh,
the way the conversion of the
dance all sided, you know,
human relations,
the ships into instrumental relationships.
Um, I think I briefly
mentioned, uh, and, uh,
the lecture on a LDR nation or,
and probably also lecture on, uh, uh, uh,
uh, v Bieber. Um, uh,
that this is actually very similar to the
ideas of a George Lowe Kotch who was a
Marxist if he lost a fair and
who developed the theory of Rafe.
He, Keisha, uh,
the Labor is developing the
theory of descent chance, man,
what is the problem of moved?
Only thing that's the lost
the enchanter the garden.
That's The r two rationale is stick to
colds to instrumental at a time when look
archer is shifting from,
Hey,
y'all two marks and invents
the idea of life vacation.
And they happened to bull
live at that time. Um,
in Heidelberg and, uh, George look arch,
when was a young man at
that time in his twenties.
It was a freak from the gas and the house
in the Viva House in the saloon around
by Mariana Weber's.
So that is clearly a mutual
influence on low arch,
unique interpretation of Marx,
theory of alienation. Uh,
that's human relationships
are becoming re fied and,
uh, uh, [inaudible],
uh, for, uh, you know,
instrumentalization of
life, which is, uh, uh,
I think distinctly different and
worse from the theory of an army and
alienation. Okay. Uh, um,
uh, a final law and the, uh, [inaudible],
uh,
our human nature.
What was his theory of human nature?
And here,
um, uh, uh,
uh, the, uh,
can see a sharp distinction between,
uh,
Mark's and,
and Viber.
Mark's meanly following a Russo's line.
Basic God. He believed that, you know,
he did not have the notion of a
state of nature to any longer.
By the mid 19th century,
people got tired and yet trad off it.
Um, uh, but, uh, uh,
he used the term a species being of
what is the essence human essence.
Uh, uh, well he said, uh,
the essentially humans are fine.
Uh,
uh, uh, it is the society
which is the problem,
not the individual. Um, it, uh,
so this is exactly, you
know, Daryl soy yen, uh, uh,
inspiration in Marx society core apps
and the state of nature of the very good
at mice, even ads. I think I
ordered, they made this point,
but let me underline one more
time. He goes beyond, um,
our last show because
Rousseau, so the um, uh,
lobos savage as a savage, as, as a,
as an individual who has to be
brought into society at that point.
March disagrees with Rousseau.
He sees we were born in society,
they are social by nature, right?
So are we are not only good,
but there are also social
and it is so sad. Eve,
each quarter up sauce which creates US
egoistic individuals will compete with
each other and kill each other, right?
This is exactly the opposite, right,
of hops and a big step beyond
Russo's theory of human nature.
Now,
Durkheim is actually much closer
to hops in his notion of uh,
uh, uh, uh, human nature, uh,
because he believes tonight that's
social pathologies and merge.
And that is a vacuum
of control over people.
That's when you have crime and Swiss shy,
the prosecution and whatever.
Uh, uh, and therefore,
uh, uh, he had a skeptical
view of human nature.
Unless we are controlled,
then we can be easier,
right? That is the fundamental issue,
right. What you have to fix, uh,
uh, is, uh, uh, uh,
making sure that the individuals,
mmm.
Develop the platform value system.
Thank you Rodney Marsh and
have a wonderful weekend. Yeah.
See you the last week of the semester.